Will the Pryde of the X-Men ever make it back
to the big screen?
Or have plans for a Kitty Pryde feature officially
fallen through the floor?
In a recent sitdown with ComicBook, Deadpool
director Tim Miller discussed the long-awaited
solo feature for fan favorite mutant Kitty
Pryde, which he had been developing before
Fox Studios' acquisition by Disney earlier
this year.
His comments were, we're sorry to report,
not encouraging.
Before the much-ballyhooed merger, Miller
had been all set to direct the flick from
a script by comics legend Brian Michael Bendis.
Pryde has been a Marvel mainstay for nearly
40 years; with her ability to phase through
solid matter and her quirky, sardonic sense
of humor, she quickly endeared herself to
readers, helping to propel sales of X-Men
comics into the stratosphere in the '80s.
The character seems like she would have been
a fine fit for Miller, who did an excellent
job of bringing Deadpool's ass-kicking, profanely
humorous aesthetic to the screen in the Merc
with a Mouth's first solo outing.
Likewise, it would have been fascinating to
see Bendis' big-screen take on the character;
among the many heroes he's created for Marvel
over the years is Jessica Jones, a tough,
complex female character who translated well
to live-action in her unfortunately canceled
Netflix series.
But unfortunately, Miller has confirmed what
many fans anticipated: the Kitty Pryde project
is dead in the water.
Miller said,
"I love the X-Men.
I don't expect Marvel to call me and say,
'Come do the X-Men,' so I'm not waiting for
that.
I was really excited about my Kitty Pryde
movie.
[...] It'll never happen now."
"The X-Men don't have room for whiny brats!"
"Just who are you calling whiny?
I'll show you!
I'll —"
"Hold it, Kitty."
Miller's comments are a pretty radical departure
from Bendis' response when he was asked for
an update on the project this past February.
In response to a fan query on Twitter, Bendis
said that he was working on the script at
that time, failing to even make mention of
the impending acquisition of the studio which
had greenlit the film.
Alas, things seem to have taken a significant
turn for the worse for the project in the
intervening months, and that's not all the
bad news that Miller has had to endure as
of late.
His second feature directorial effort, Terminator:
Dark Fate, flopped mightily at the box office
despite relatively solid reviews, making it
another franchise that probably won't be coming
back anytime soon.
We're of the opinion, though, that the helmer
shouldn't be quite so pessimistic.
Deadpool was a rousing success, single-handedly
proving that R-rated superhero pictures were
viable in today's age of non-stop PG-13 blockbusters.
It remains to be seen if Disney will bring
him into the fold to put his talents to use
with a new Marvel property — but it'd probably
be a good idea to reach out.
While nothing is official yet, all signs are
indicating that Marvel Studios will eventually
give the greenlight to a third Deadpool movie
at some point in the near future.
Star Ryan Reynolds, who was born to play the
role, has openly expressed his hope that the
three-quel will get the green light sooner
rather than later, and the writers of the
first two installments, Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick, are confident that it's just a matter
of time before the flick is put into production.
For that matter, Marvel Studios' brass have
indicated that they expect to eventually recast
every member of the X-Men except Deadpool,
and Disney CEO Bob Iger has publicly said
that the Mouse House would be just fine with
Marvel making an R-rated superhero film.
Add to this the fact that Reynolds was recently
seen popping by Marvel Studios' offices for
a visit, and it all adds up the strong possibility
that we'll get some news about Deadpool 3
before too long.
Other than a potential third outing for Deadpool,
though, it looks like every single one of
the Marvel-related projects that were in development
at Fox before the merger are dying on the
vine.
The Channing Tatum-starring Gambit, in development
for the better part of a decade, recently
received a vote of no-confidence from formerly
attached director Doug Liman;
Logan director James Mangold has said that
a planned spin-off featuring Dafne Keen's
X-23 is unlikely to happen, and James Franco's
Multiple Man failed to reach a significant
stage of development before the merger, meaning
that it, too, is almost certainly done for.
"So good."
It simply makes more sense for Marvel Studios
to develop these characters for the screen
in their own inimitable fashion rather than
to continue on the course that Fox was plotting
— especially after the critical and commercial
failure of the final Fox-produced X-Men film,
Dark Phoenix.
Having said that, a Miller-directed, Bendis-scripted
Kitty Pryde flick sounds like something we
would want to see, and if Marvel head honcho
Kevin Feige has any designs on introducing
the character into the MCU, he could do worse
than to bring the pair in for a chat.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.